قرار طالبان حظر تعليم الجامعي للنساء
لاجل غير مسما اشعل عاصفه ادانات داخليه
وخارجيه داخليا هذه المره بعيدا عن
المنافسه السياسيه عبر زعيم الحزب
الاسلامي الافغاني كلب الدين حكم تيار عن
رفضه لقرارات طالبان الاخيره واصفا اياها
بالمخزيه هذا القرار غير عقلاني بمنع
الفتيات من الدراسه في الجامعات يجب فهم
الاولويات وتجنب القرارات غير المجديه
قال وزير الخارجيه الافغانيه السابقه
منع الفتيات من الجامعه خطوه ضد القيم
الاسلاميه وحقوق الانسان حرمان الفتيات من
التعليم يعرض حياه العائله العائلات وتقدم
افغانستان ومستقبلها لخطر حقيقي
كذلك سيكلف الحركه مزيدا من العزله
ينبغي على طالبان ان تتوقع ان هذا القرار
الذي يتعارض مع الالتزامات التي تعهد بها
مرارا وعلنا لشعبهم سيترتب عليه تكاليف
ملموسه
الامم المتحده بدورها استنكرت حرمان
الافغانيات من حقهن بالتعليم وحذرت من ان
ذلك مؤشر للمزيد من سلب الحقوق الاجتماعيه
بل وحتى السياسيه من جانبه استنكر بيان
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي الشديد اللهجه
قرارات طالبان مذكرا بان المنظمه سبق ان
حضرت الحركه نوفمبر الماضي من مثل تلك
التصرفات
سين ستطالبان لقد رفضا على مستوى
الاكاديميين في افغانستان ودفعت البعض
منهم للتعبير عن ذلك بالاستقاله في معرفه
اصوات الافغانيه مطالبه بمظاهره حاشده في
كافه انحاء البلاد